Okay, so welcome to video number 27. We
are still going through the trade idea
generation process.
We are in the quantitative processing
phase still. So now we're going to look at
some of the earnings
growth profiles that we identified earlier
when we were looking at potential longs
and
shorts. And we're going to be looking at
turnaround stories and value traps. So if
you recall, when
we were looking at long idea processing
and short idea processing, we looked at
multiple
earnings growth profiles. And obviously,
earnings growth is always a forward
looking metric in our
overall quantitative and qualitative
dashboard as part of the bottom up
microeconomic trade idea
generation process. So in the previous
videos of long idea and short idea
processing, we identified a
whole bunch of earnings growth profiles
that we defined as not ideal, or close to
ideal. Now when earnings
growth profiles are not ideal or close to
ideal, when we're processing for both long
and short ideas.
These types of earnings growth profiles
tend to fall into the categories of what
we call turnaround stories
and value traps. But obviously, not all
the time, we have to be a little bit
careful here, because we could have
situations, for example, like revenue
growth stories, where the management
operating plan is purposely
to not make earnings. So they have
spurious earnings growth, spurious EPS and
spurious earnings growth.
So the management operating plan is to
reinvest revenue and hence any earnings
back into growing the top line.
So we have to be a little bit careful here
that we are actually identifying genuine X
growth stories that could
potentially be turnaround stories or
potentially value traps. Now, with
reference to the earnings growth profiles
covered in the previous two videos and in
the downloadable spreadsheets, earnings
growth profiles for longs and earnings
growth profiles
And for short, the cases that exhibited
non-ideal or not close to ideal earnings
growth profiles were, for example, in
earnings growth profiles for longs cases
7, 8, 9 and 10 and for short cases 5, 8
and 9.
Remember, these are not ideal or close to
ideal classic long and short earnings
growth setups for a portfolio.
However, as traders and portfolio
managers, we are always looking for
opportunities and non-ideal
from our perspective does not mean that
it's not useful.
So, from a portfolio management
perspective, the majority of times when
GDP is forecasted to grow and
stock markets are forecasted to make
gains, your portfolio bias as a manager
will be long with a
natural tendency towards leaning at
cyclical growth on the long side and X
growth cyclical with defensives on the
short side of the portfolio.
However, there's obviously going to be
periods in time when value, for example,
in the stock market is more attractive
than growth.
So, times when you are likely to have a
flat to negative bias in your portfolio,
so a flat to short bias in the portfolio.
Additionally, it can be argued that even
in times when you have a very strong
conviction towards GDP expansion
and a net long portfolio bias, we
shouldn't just be always long growth
stocks and cyclicality and short all X
growth stocks or defensives.
In this situation, if the macroeconomic
environment shifts very quickly,
we can get caught out and experience large
drawdowns in our portfolio.
This is because our diversification in the
portfolio, although there's numerous
positions, can actually be flawed.
So, the question is, in that situation,
are you really diverse if you are long all
cyclical growth names
and short all X growth and defensive names
in the portfolio?
Well, probably not.
But at all times, you should know your
risk.
So, this is your call.
A lot of these good practices are covered,
for example, with Chris Quill in the
Fundamentals of Portfolio
Management section of the PTM video
series.
So, of course, at any one time, we will
have, as long short portfolio managers,
portfolio volatility.
And we choose, as risk takers, a high
enough level of volatility to expose
ourselves to the opportunity to make
money.
But, of course, there's two sides to that
coin.
The other side of the coin is that you're
taking risk.
Now, if there is a change in the macro
environment, the risk of the portfolio can
change.
So, your implied portfolio volatility can
go up unexpectedly and you end up taking
more risk than you want.
Plus, betas can change in a new risk
environment.
So, we have non-beta adjusted risk.
Also, if we want our diversification to
actually work well in our long short
portfolio,
we want to make sure that our portfolio
correlation is not too high.
So, it must be low enough so that
everything in the portfolio, our longs and
our shorts,
don't all move together at the same time
all at once.
We want to be exposed to dislocation as
well as volatility.
So, this is where earnings growth profiles
that are alternative to our classic,
ideal,
or close to ideal earnings growth profiles
come in handy because they add an extra
tool
or extra opportunities in our armory to
the long short portfolio management trade
idea generation process.
And, as always, we start with the
quantitative.
Now, as mentioned, when we are processing
the quant,
we have to be very careful when we are
processing the quant and identifying
potential turnaround stories
or value traps because when we are
processing, we could bump into revenue
growth stories.
So, in the previous video, we showed you
how to identify potential short trade
ideas
based on various earnings growth profiles
and a price earnings multiple backdrop.
So, the process of identifying X growth
stocks as potential shorts
means that the stock very clearly must be
beyond its growth phase.
So, it's not a revenue growth story.
Now, when you look at further metrics like
revenue growth,
a stock may still be in its growth phase
and the management operating plan
is to actually choose to reinvest revenue
and therefore earnings into growing the
top line,
the top line revenue.
So, again, don't think because you see
negative earnings growth on paper
that a stock is automatically a short.
It just isn't.
You always have to do further work.
And when you do further work beyond the
quant identification process on potential
shorts
that exhibit the earnings growth profiles
that look like shorts on paper,
If you then discover that the stock is a
revenue growth story, then, of course, you
re-categorize it as that.
In fact, it may even be a potential long.
So, remember, this is always simply an
identification process.
Now, when we're processing in the quant
and identifying what could be potential
earnings growth profiles
that exhibit a turnaround story or value
trap profile, the same logic applies here.
If we discover it's a revenue growth
story, we simply re-categorize it.
Now, regardless, if you do identify a
revenue growth story in the background,
you're probably going to see anyway that
it shows up or is reflected in the PE
multiple versus the sector.
So, it won't have a PE profile that's
typical of a turnaround story or value
trap.
So, it's very likely that the PE of a
revenue growth story is going to be high
relative to the sector
because the market will be paying for its
revenue growth and its way out or far out
earnings potential.
So, just bear in mind that when you're
processing in the quant phase, looking for
longs, looking for shorts,
potentially categorizing turnaround or
value traps, we obviously have our
different categories.
We have our classic long ideas or ideal or
close to ideal long ideas.
We have our classic earnings growth
profile setups for short ideas.
We have our ideal and we have our
non-ideal and we also have our phases for
short ideas.
So, phase 1, 2, 3, 4 and 5 and we also
have our categories of turnaround stories
and value traps.
So, typical earnings growth profiles of
turnaround stories and value traps.
But, always remember the market can like
and dislike stocks for different reasons
other than earnings growth potential.
Most typically, these are revenue growth
stories, whether the market likes or
dislikes their revenue growth.
And if we bump into those at any time
during our processing, we recategorize as
a revenue story.
So, for the purposes of this video, we're
going to assume that in your processing,
in your quant processing,
that you have not identified a revenue
growth story here.
And what you have identified is actually a
turnaround or value trap.
So, if you recall, when we were looking at
long idea quant processing,
we had our cases number 7, 8, 9 and 10.
And what we discovered was that all of
these cases were either not ideal or close
to ideal in terms of the classic long
setup,
where we either had sequentially positive
earnings growth momentum or we had close
to that.
And if you remember these cases 7, 8, 9
and 10.
Cases number 7 and 8, the backdrop was
that we have positive EPS, so the company
is in profit.
And cases number 9 and 10, we have
negative EPS, so the company, the
operation is loss making.
Further to that, we discovered that cases
number 7 and case number 10 didn't even
constitute any real opportunity for us
when we're looking for long ideas.
Not only were these cases 7 and 10, not
ideal or close to ideal in terms of the
classic long setup that we look for as
traders,
but they probably are not even genuine
turnaround stories.
So, let's have a look at these cases.
Case number 7, we have positive EPS in the
background with negative earnings growth
in year 1.
Then earnings growth recovers below sector
average for year 2.
And here, as traders, portfolio managers,
it's not ideal setup.
It's not even close to an ideal setup.
We may, on a relative basis to the sector,
simply have an opportunity cost here to
own the sector.
And that is obviously not our job as
traders.
Looking at it through a long ideas lens,
this is obviously not ideal.
And it's likely to not even constitute a
real turnaround story.
Remember, the backdrop here is still
positive EPS.
It's not a loss making operation.
So, it's more than likely that you're
going to find this type of earnings growth
profile in an early phase if it's going X
growth.
It's not going to be likely that this
stock is in phase 4 or phase 5.
But even if it is, because the market is
forecasting earnings growth in the second
period to be lower than the sector by a
decent amount.
But even if it is in phase 4 or phase 5,
if we took a position in this type of
earnings growth profile, a long position,
we would essentially be arguing with the
market.
If we find ourselves in phase 4 or phase
5, we would want to see a much higher
earnings growth number for the second
period in absolute terms and in relative
terms to the sector.
If we look at case 8, this could be a
genuine turnaround, this could be a
different story to case number 7.
The earnings growth profile is similar to
case number 7.
We have a positive EPS backdrop and
earnings growth is falling in the first
year, but then it recovers to a round
sector average.
So, this could actually be a potential
turnaround story when we're looking at it
through a long ideas lens.
And it could be a genuine turnaround story
if it actually is in phase 4 or phase 5.
But remember, with cases 7 and case 8,
there is a backdrop of positive EPS.
So, we have to make sure that if we're
looking for turnaround stories, that we
actually get the opportunity here to make
potentially big returns.
So, we would much rather see an earnings
growth profile like case number 8,
where the turnaround in earnings growth is
big or bigger than, for example, case
number 7.
And we see evidence of that from analyst
estimates and it's coming from a position
of weakness.
So, we have a bigger opportunity.
So, it's coming from a low base, like in
phase 4 or phase 5.
Moving on to case number 9.
This is where we have a case where we've
got a backdrop of negative EPS.
So, it's a similar profile coming from an
earnings growth position of weakness to
relative strength in year 2.
But we have a backdrop of negative EPS,
the company, the operation is loss making.
So, we have negative earnings growth in
period 1, with a backdrop of negative EPS,
a loss making company.
And the earnings growth in period 1 is
underperforming the sector.
In period 2, in year 2, we have a massive
turnaround.
We have a big turnaround in earnings
growth.
High numbers like 100% turnaround.
And the company is now moving from a loss
making position to a flat EPS position or
positive EPS position.
So, the expectations here from the market
are wild.
They are turbo.
And versus similar earnings growth
profiles, it offers the biggest potential
turnaround.
But there is a flip side.
There is another side to that coin.
There is high risk with this one.
So, there could also be the biggest
disappointment.
We could also have the greatest downside
and it could be a total value trap.
So, it's both opportunistic and dangerous
at the same time.
Then we have our case number 10.
This is most similar in terms of earnings
growth profile.
Most similar to case 9 because we're
dealing here with a loss making operation,
negative EPS.
In year 2, in this earnings growth
profile, the losses continue, but they are
declining at a slower rate.
So, when we look at this earnings growth
profile, it's obviously not an ideal,
long, classic setup earnings growth
profile.
However, there could be a situation in the
market here.
Of course, there's a possibility that
analysts in year 2 may be being too
bearish on their EPS, their forward EPS
estimates.
The question is, is it a genuine
turnaround story?
Well, with this profile, especially when
you put it into the context of having the
potential of case number 9, where we're
also coming from a loss making position.
If something like case number 9 is
available, why would we ever play in this
type of situation?
It's probably not worth playing.
We want to see in the market evidence of a
turbo expectation of a turnaround.
So, when we're processing in the quant
phase and we're identifying earnings
growth profiles and categorizing stocks
with their earnings growth profile.
Our cases 7, 8, 9, and 10 from a genuine
long idea lens perspective.
Cases number 7 and case number 10 are
probably not going to work for us.
What we want is evidence of a really good
solid turnaround in EPS.
And our cases number 8 and 9 are probably
most likely going to provide that profile.
But what we really want to see is genuine
evidence that the companies are coming
from a very weak position.
So, we want to see them already beaten up.
We want to see the stocks really beaten up
and we'd love to see them in phase 4 or
phase 5.
Now, let's remind ourselves of the
backdrop of the PE multiple profiles as
well.
So, when we're looking at trade ideas
through a long lens in the quant phase,
what's our ideal setup for the PE?
Well, if you recall, we have a PE 1 that
is higher than the sector and a PE 2 that
is higher than the sector.
And we have in period 2 a lower PE than
period 1 because EPS is higher in period
2.
Also, we like to see evidence that the
sector is growing EPS as well.
What is not ideal from a PE profile
perspective when we're looking at long
trade ideas,
the backdrop we don't want to see, that's
not ideal, is when we have a lower stock
price earnings ratio
than the sector in both periods.
Even though for both the stock and the
sector in period 2 we're getting higher
EPS and we do have positive EPS
overall, even though this is the case, the
market is telling us that they dislike the
company.
The valuation is on a discount to the
sector.
Now, where it gets interesting from a
trader's perspective when we're looking at
the quant
through a long lens, through a long trade
idea lens, is when we see price earnings
multiple setups
relative to the sector where we have a big
turnaround.
So, where we have a turnaround exhibited
or evidence of a turnaround exhibited in
the price earnings
multiple.
So, if you think about our case 9 scenario
where we had negative earnings growth with
a loss-making
company in period 1 and then in period 2
we had a big jump positive in earnings
growth and the earnings
growth was 100% in our example so the
company is essentially recovering all of
its losses.
So, going from negative EPS to either flat
or positive EPS.
Well, in that situation it's certainly not
our ideal PE backdrop setup but it does
potentially provide us with a big
opportunity for a turnaround story.
So, naturally in period 1 if we are
experiencing a company when we're doing
our quant processing
that has negative EPS, it's going to
exhibit in period 1 a negative PE ratio
because it's the current stock
price divided by forward-looking negative
EPS.
And in a turnaround story it's always nice
to see in period 1 that the PE is negative
and on a big discount to the sector.
Obviously with its negative or loss-making
operation.
And then in period 2 we're getting our
100% earnings growth.
So, the company is making all of its
losses back.
It's eliminating its losses in period 2
and potentially even more than that.
So, making a profit in a scenario like
this we're using current stock price and
forward-looking
EPS for year 2 and it's likely that we're
going to see or have exhibited a PE ratio
in period 2
that is extremely high and obviously on a
big premium to the sector.
So, this type of PE backdrop potentially
gives us a big opportunity for a
turnaround story
as long as it genuinely is a turnaround
story and it's not a revenue growth story
and it's part of the management operating
plan to have negative EPS in period 1 and
flat EPS in period 2
or even showing a small profit in period
2.
Therefore, creating a scenario of very
small EPS and very high PE.
So, we have the law of small numbers.
This is something we're going to discuss
later.
So, as long as it's not a revenue growth
story and it's part of the management
operating plan
to incur losses or tiny profits and to
grow the top line and it essentially is
still a growth stock,
it can provide us with a big opportunity
as traders potentially as a turnaround
story.
And also, when we look in the market, we
want to see that the stock has been beaten
up.
The stock is down a lot and it's in phase
4 or phase 5.
This could potentially, if it's a genuine
turnaround story with this type of PE
profile
and for example, a case number 9 earnings
growth profile,
it could provide us with a big
opportunity, especially if the stock has
been beaten up
in phase 4 and it's in phase 4 or phase 5.
Now, let's have a look at this from a PEG
perspective, a PEG ratio perspective.
If you recall, the ideal PEG setup for
long ideas is that we have a PEG that's at
a premium
to the sector in both year one and year
two.
So, remembering the formula for PEG, it's
the PE ratio divided by the earnings
growth percentage for each period.
So, when we see a higher PEG in period one
and period two, and we see that the PEG is
on a premium to the sector,
this is ideal for us when we're looking at
long ideas because we have evidence from
the market
that the market is paying a premium for
the growth rate.
So, remember, this is when we have in the
formula obviously a positive stock price,
but we also have the backdrop of positive
EPS and sequentially positive earnings
growth momentum.
So, when we take the positive high PE and
we divide it by the growth rates,
we get a positive number for the PEG.
So, the market is paying a premium for the
growth rate of the stock relative to the
sector.
Now, when we think about what our PEG
setup would look like,
when we think of it in the context of a
potential turnaround story,
if you think about what PEG is, so the PE
ratio divided by the earnings growth rate
for each period,
we can look at both of our cases and we
can see what happens to PEG.
So, in both of our cases, four potential
turnaround stories.
So, let's think about case number eight
for a moment, where in period one, we have
a positive
price earnings ratio, but we have a
negative earnings growth rate.
So, remember, in case number eight, we
have positive EPS.
So, we have a positive stock price and a
positive EPS, thus creating a positive PE.
But we are dividing that positive PE by a
negative earnings growth number.
So, we end up with a negative PEG in
period one.
And from a PEG perspective and a
turnaround perspective, we want to see it
on a discount to the sector.
Moving into year two, period two for case
number eight, what do we have?
Well, we have a positive stock price and
we have a positive EPS, but we also have a
positive earnings
growth number. So, we end up with a
positive PE divided by a positive earnings
growth percentage.
So, we end up with a positive PEG in the
second period.
And because for case number eight, this is
a turnaround story,
when we look at PEG two for the stock
relative to the sector, the numbers can,
of course,
be slightly off or quite wild when
relative to the sector.
So, we don't put as much emphasis on the
importance of PEG two for a turnaround
story
when comparing it relative to the sector.
So, in period two, that PEG number for the
stock can be the same.
It can be slightly higher, it can be way
higher, or it can be slightly lower, or it
could be close to zero.
And the sector number can just be higher
or lower in comparison to that.
What's important for us is to have
evidence that the PEG is simply going from
a negative to a positive position.
And even with PEG one, with case number
eight, because the PEG is just negative,
we obviously place less importance on PEG
in our analysis, because it just comes out
as a negative
perspective, and doesn't really tell us
much in terms of what the market thinks of
the stock
on from a valuation perspective, when we
look at it with PEG.
With case number nine, this is where PEG
becomes less important to our analysis as
traders,
when we're looking at long trade ideas,
because the numbers can just be very wild.
So, think about period number one in terms
of the PEG one.
We're going to have, for case number nine,
a negative PE ratio divided by negative
earnings growth.
So, obviously, this is a bad situation to
be in for the company.
It has negative EPS.
So, therefore, with a positive stock price
and a negative EPS, we have a negative PE
ratio,
and we have negative earnings growth.
So, the issue is here is that the PEG is
not reflective of reality.
The PEG one, when you divide a negative by
a negative, is going to come out
as positive and it could likely be on a
premium to the sector.
So, it doesn't reflect the reality of the
situation.
So, we put a lot less importance on PEG
ratio for case number nine.
In period number two for case number nine,
what are we ending up with?
Well, we are ending up with positive EPS.
So, either it's going to be flat or
positive EPS coming from a negative EPS
position.
So, what's going to happen there?
We're going to have positive EPS and
positive stock price, therefore, a
positive PE ratio.
Additionally, in period number two, we're
going to have positive earnings growth.
So, when we're dividing the positive by
the positive, we end up with a positive
PEG.
And the PEG two for the stock can simply
be the same higher or lower than the PEG
two for the sector.
So, with case number nine, like case
number eight, we're putting a lot less
importance
on PEG ratio overall in our analysis, but
what we're looking to see is a
normalization of PEG.
So, we're looking to see evidence when we
move from period one to period two,
where in period one, we have a situation,
whether it's case number eight or case
number nine,
where the PEG is not really reflective of
reality and doesn't really tell us much,
where we're moving from this to a period,
period two, where the PEG ratio becomes
somewhat normalized.
So, when we are going through our
quantitative process and we are
identifying long trade ideas
and we think we've found what could
potentially be a turnaround story, so a
case number eight
and case number nine, when we see our PEG
profiles, we are placing less emphasis on
their importance
for us in our interpretation and
understanding of what is actually going on
with the stock.
What we need to be doing is focusing on
the PE ratio in isolation and comparing it
to the sector
to get a better understanding of how the
market values the stock relative to the
sector and whether
that means anything, or we're looking at
the earnings growth number and we're
looking at that
earnings growth number for the stock in
isolation relative to the sector and
whether that means anything
in our understanding and interpretation of
what's going on.
The PEG ratio, the numbers can just be a
little bit all over the place for case
number eight and case number nine.
So, we simply take note of it, we
acknowledge it and we look to see if
there's an actual normalization
in the PEG rate for period two versus
period one and we just understand that the
PEG overall,
when we just divide the numbers by one
another, the numbers can just be
misleading as to what is actually
going on. And then what we do is we move
further and we do further work digging
deeper to figure out
what is actually going on in the stock and
whether it's a genuine turnaround story or
not.
What we really want to know is whether it
genuinely has been an ex-growth stock for
a long time and the
stock is potentially down a lot and is
beaten up and we are sitting in a phase
four or phase five situation.
Because in that context, with the PE ratio
and the earnings growth profile,
we are probably looking at a potential
turnaround story.
Now, let's move on to short idea
processing when we're looking at potential
turnarounds.
And if you recall, there were three
earnings growth profiles from our set of
earnings growth profiles
when we were processing for short ideas,
there were three earnings growth profiles
that were not ideal
for the short setup and weren't close to
ideal for the short setup.
So we have our case number five, our case
number eight and our case number nine.
And if you recall, case number five was in
a EPS backdrop that was still positive
EPS.
And case number eight and nine were
actually loss making operations.
So let's have a look first at our case
number five, where we have positive EPS.
So the earnings growth profile is like our
cases seven and eight from long ideas.
When we're looking at the earnings growth
profile through a long lens, we have
positive EPS,
where we have positive EPS, where we have
positive EPS, where we have negative EPS,
where we have positive EPS.
So we have a positive EPS, where we have
negative EPS, where we have negative EPS.
And when we're doing that, it's obviously
not an ideal short setup, especially if
it's in a phase four or phase five
scenario.
And of course, if it's very low market
cap, what we want to be doing here from a
short perspective
is catching this type of earnings growth
profile in the phase two and phase three
moves that are down in the stock,
assuming that the earnings growth two
number is a hope or fantasy number set by
the analysts.
So it is very dangerous to be shorting
this type of earnings growth profile when
it's in phase four or phase five.
We want to be catching this type of
earnings growth profile in phase two and
phase three moves down,
assuming that the EPS number, the earnings
growth number in period two is somewhat of
a hope or fantasy number.
And what really matters here, and this is
how you have to look at everything
when we're looking at these types of
earnings growth profiles.
What really matters here when we're
shorting is what part of the X growth
phase are we actually in?
So are we early to the party or late to
the party?
Has it just gone X growth? So are we in
phase one or phase two, for example?
Or has it been X growth for a long time
and the stock is down a lot, say 50, 60,
70, 80%
plus and the stock is sitting in a
potential phase four or phase five
scenario?
An early stage X growth stock is
potentially a short on this type of
earnings growth profile.
A late stage X growth stock, which has a
management operating plan to create an EPS
turnaround
and has been in phase four or phase five
for a long time, can actually be a value
play from the long side.
So we might we may see, for example, value
investors coming into the market to pick
up that stock.
From a short perspective, this can be very
dangerous for us.
So case five has potential as a short as
long as it's early on in the X growth
phase.
Now let's have a look at case number
eight.
So for our short ideas case number eight,
this is the loss making case nine from our
long ideas profiles.
Analysts are forecasting a total
turnaround in EPS from a loss making
position to a positive profit making
position.
So we're looking at case number nine from
long ideas profiles, but we're looking at
it through a short ideas lens.
This is our short ideas case number eight.
Now looking at it through a short ideas
lens, we definitely don't want to be
exposing ourselves
to this type of profile if it's in phase
four or phase five.
This is an extreme turnaround in the EPS
and EPS growth.
From a short ideas perspective, we want to
catch this in phase two and phase three.
If it's just gone X growth and the
earnings growth two number is a hope or
fantasy number.
So this is a very, very opportunistic
situation for longs.
And it's dangerous for shorts, especially
in phase four and phase five.
Now thinking in the bigger picture here.
It's obvious that our case number five and
our case number eight are not ideal
situations when we're looking for short
setups.
If we go back to case number five for a
moment.
And we think of the notion of whether we
are going with the market or we're going
against the market.
If we look at the earnings growth profile
of the stock in absolute terms,
we go from negative earnings growth to
positive earnings growth from period one
to period two.
On an absolute basis, we are arguing with
the market here if we are looking to short
the stock.
On a relative basis, however, it's
debatable as to whether we are arguing
with the market here.
Because in both periods, the stock's
earnings growth is lower than the sector.
So it has potential to be a short
dependent on what stage of the X growth
phase it's in.
Remember, this is a positive EPS backdrop.
The stock is experiencing negative
earnings growth in period one.
So that's not a great situation if you
have positive EPS as a company.
And then the analysts on their forward
looking estimates for the second year are
forecasting some earnings growth
potential.
That may not happen.
If this is in phase two and phase three,
this would be a potential short
opportunity.
However, if it's in phase four and phase
five and it's been in the earnings growth
decline,
so gone X growth for a long time and it's
in phase four and phase five.
This is when you're late to the party.
So this can end up being dangerous for a
short.
So when we think of this earnings growth
profile from a short perspective and
whether we are arguing with the market or
not,
it's debatable in all phases.
But we would obviously much rather catch
something like this in phase two and phase
three rather than phase four or phase five
because we have a higher chance
that the earnings growth two number is a
hope or fantasy number and we have much
more downside potential in the stock.
And with our further work on the stock, on
the company, both quantitative and
qualitative,
we can increase our chances by
understanding whether this earnings growth
two number is likely to be a hope or
fantasy number.
When we think of our case number eight
from a short ideas perspective,
again, where we are in the X growth phase
really matters.
Because the earnings growth profile is so
wild in comparison
to case number five and we're coming from
a loss making position.
This type of earnings growth profile when
we're in phase four and phase five is way
more dangerous.
And also in phase two and phase three
could actually present us with even bigger
opportunity,
but it can also be dangerous in phase two
and phase three as well.
From a perspective, regardless of which
phase we're in,
of whether we are arguing with the market
here or not,
this is much more likely a situation where
we are arguing with the market.
So because the EPS growth profile is so
wild and there's such a big turnaround
and analysts are forecasting such a big
turnaround.
It's likely that there's potentially a lot
of conviction around this second period
earnings growth number.
Yes, we can do further work, further
quantitative and qualitative work on this
to determine whether we think the earnings
growth number in period two is a hope or
fantasy number,
or the expectation is just simply too
high.
But remember, because the EPS turnaround,
the earnings growth turnaround, it's
coming from such a low base,
a loss making situation with EPS to a
positive situation with EPS and earnings
growth.
Regardless of which phase it's in, this
can actually be dangerous for shorts.
So similar to when we looked at this
earnings growth profile under conditions
of looking at it through a long ideas
lens,
this type of earnings growth profile for
shorts can provide the biggest profit
potential,
but it can also provide a very big loss
potential.
It's high risk.
We definitely do not want to be exposing
ourselves to this type of profile.
If a stock exhibits this profile and it's
been down quite a lot
and it's in phase four and phase five and
it's been there for a while.
We have to admit to ourselves that we are
arguing with the market
regardless of the phase that we're in.
But if we are going to expose ourselves to
something like this,
we want to be making sure that it's much
higher probability.
So we want to be catching something like
this in phase two and phase three.
Moving on to case number nine.
This is like our case number 10 from long
ideas profiles,
but it's a loss making operation.
So when we're looking at this type of
profile through a short ideas lens,
we definitely don't want to be exposing
ourselves to this type of profile in phase
four and phase five.
We obviously again want to catch this type
of profile in phase two and phase three,
when it's close to have just gone X growth
and the earnings growth number in period
two,
we can determine that it's somewhat of a
hope or fantasy number from analysts.
It's very dangerous to be short earnings
growth profiles like this,
especially in phase four and phase five.
Now, when we think about our price
earnings ratio backdrop,
if you recall, our ideal PE setup for
short trade ideas.
So we have positive EPS, therefore a
positive PE.
And in both period one and period two, we
have the stock PE on a discount to the
sector.
We have sector EPS rising, therefore we
have a lower PE2 than PE1 for the sector.
And for the stock, we have EPS falling,
therefore we have a higher PE2 versus PE1
for the stock.
But the stock's PE is on a discount to the
sector in both periods.
This is our ideal price earnings ratio
setup for short ideas.
An example of a non-ideal price earnings
ratio profile setup for short ideas would
be if we had
EPS that's negative in both years.
So we have a negative PE1 and a negative
PE2.
So the company is a loss making operation.
And it simply has, because of negative
EPS, a negative PE1 and a negative PE2.
So loss making in both periods.
If we see this type of PE profile in the
backdrop, when a company is in phase four
or
phase five of the X growth phase, this is
probably a turnaround story or potential
value trap.
If you see this type of PE profile in the
context of a stock that just has been
going up a lot and
and continues to trend up and hasn't even
gone X growth, so it hasn't even entered a
phase one scenario.
It's very likely that you're looking at a
revenue growth story.
Therefore, from a short trade ideas
perspective, this is not an ideal setup.
It's very unlikely that you're going to
pull up this type of PE profile and we are
sitting
nicely in a phase two or phase three
situation because the company is losing
money in both periods.
Well, it's forecasted to lose money in
both periods.
And the stock will probably have moved
quite a lot already.
And if it is genuinely X growth, then it's
probably going to be in a phase four
or phase five situation and you're going
to be late to the party.
Now let's think of our PEG profiles for
short trade ideas.
If you recall for our ideal sequentially
negative earnings growth profile or even
some of our close to ideal negative
earnings growth profiles, you'll recall
that if we just have
negative earnings growth, we're going to
end up with a negative PEG.
Therefore, there's no ideal PEG set up
with our ideal shorts or close to ideal
negative earnings growth profile potential
shorts.
We just get a negative PEG and it doesn't
really tell us much about what's really
going on
with the stock relative to the sector.
We have to look at price earnings ratio.
So how the market values the company
relative to the sector.
And we have to look at that in isolation.
And we also have to look at the earnings
growth percentage numbers.
So the changes in EPS on a percentage
basis in isolation relative to the sector
as well.
And not pay attention to the PEG numbers
in this situation when we have negative
earnings growth profiles.
Now, when we think of our cases of
potential turnarounds through a short
ideas lens,
if we think of case number five and what
the PEG profile is going to look like
there.
Well, in the period number one, we're
going to have a negative PEG.
Because the backdrop is that the stock has
a positive EPS.
And therefore, it's going to have a
positive price earnings ratio, but it has
negative earnings growth.
So it's going to have a negative PEG one.
Now, in the second period, the backdrop is
still that we have positive EPS.
But we have earnings growth that is
positive.
And remember, in our example with case
number five, the earnings growth profile
was that the percentage
number for earnings growth in period two
was below the sector average earnings
growth for period two.
So in this situation, it's likely that the
PEG two for the stock is going to be
higher than the sector
because we are dividing by a smaller
earnings growth number.
However, it can be the same or lower than
the sector.
It really depends on the relationship
between the EPS and the earnings growth
percentage number.
So in period one, it's likely that the
negative PEG is going to be on a discount
to the sector.
And in period two, the positive PEG is
going to be on a premium to the sector,
but it could actually be the same or lower
depending on the relationship between EPS
and the percentage number.
So depending on the numbers, how they've
changed from period one to period two,
we can get a PEG that's the same or lower,
but it's likely that it's going to be
higher.
But again, we reached the same conclusions
here with PEG overall when we consider
what messages
we can take from the market when we're
thinking about the PEG ratio and what it
means for the stock.
In case number five, we again take the
same message that what we're seeing in the
PEG doesn't really tell us
much about what's going on with the stock
itself. All we are seeing here is some
sort of normalization
of the PEG ratio from period one to period
two. We have to do further work and look
at the price
earnings ratio in isolation and what the
market thinks of the stock via PE and have
a look at the earnings
growth percentage profiles and understand
those in both periods as in whether they
are premium or
discount to the sector. And we have to do
further work to enable us to understand
what's really going
on with the stock. The PEG ratio doesn't
really tell us much in case number five.
When we think of PEG ratio for our next
case, case number eight, what have we got
here? Well,
the numbers are just all over the place or
PEG ratio because we have a positive PEG
in period one
because of the double negative, because
the stock has a negative EPS. Because
remember, we are a loss
making operation in case number eight.
That's what we're looking at here, a
company that has negative EPS.
So in period one, we have negative EPS. So
we have negative PE, but we also have the
double negative.
We have negative earnings growth one. So
the PEG one is just going to come out as a
positive number,
unlikely that it's a very high number and
on a premium to the sector. So again, the
PEG one here
doesn't really tell us much about what's
really going on with the company.
When we move into period two for case
number eight,
in period two, if you recall, the earnings
growth number was very high, around 100%
and EPS had gone positive from a negative
position. So we end up with a positive PE
and a very high
positive earnings growth number. So what
we're probably going to see here is
obviously a positive
PEG ratio, but we're going to see it as
being a low number and likely that it's on
a discount to the
sector in PEG two. So taking the PEG ratio
in period one and two, we really can't
read too much into this
information as to the messages it's
telling us about what the market thinks of
the stock. The numbers
are just all over the place. We just
recognize it, we take note of it, and we
understand that there's
some sort of normalization of the PEG
ratio occurring. For our case number nine
profile, when we're looking
through a short ideas lens, in PEG one, we
are again going to have a positive PEG
ratio because of the
double negative, because the stock has
negative EPS in period one. So it has a
negative PE ratio and it has
negative earnings growth. But it's likely
that our PEG one for the stock is going to
be lower than the sector
because when we're doing the double
negative division, the negative for
earnings growth is a very big number.
Moving into the second period again, we
have negative earnings growth, but the
number is smaller and we
have negative EPS. So we have a negative
PEG and we have negative earnings growth,
therefore a positive PEG two.
But the negative earnings growth number in
period two for the stock is not as big in
magnitude in the
negative as the negative earnings growth
number in period one. Therefore, when we
do the division
of the negative PE and a smaller negative
earnings growth number for the second
period, we end up with a
very high positive PEG two number. So in
summary, when we're looking at PEG
profiles,
that could be turnarounds or value traps.
We mustn't think that there's an
interpretation to these PEGs.
A positive EPS number with negative
earnings growth simply creates negative
PEG. And a negative EPS
EPS number with a negative earnings growth
number simply creates a positive PEG. So
we can't glean useful
information from these numbers because
they don't tell us much about what the
market thinks of the stock.
Our interpretation is going to be a weak
interpretation. We have to look at the
price earnings ratio valuation
and earnings growth percentage in
isolation. And we have to do further work
to interpret what's
really going on with the stock. So if the
stock is actually an X growth stock or
not, and at what stage of
X growth the stock is actually at. So are
we in a phase one, phase two, three, four
or five scenario.
So for turnaround situations, the stage at
which a stock has gone X growth is very
important.
So turnaround stories by the very
definition of what the company has
experienced in the past and in the
present. They are experiencing earnings
growth problems. So whether we're looking
at earnings
growth profiles through a long or short
lens, it's important to consider how far
along a stock is
after it has gone X growth. So first
question always to answer, has the company
actually gone X growth?
How far down the line is the company in
terms of going X growth?
How much is the stock price down? How much
is actually reflected in the stock price
move already?
How bearish are the earnings expectations
looking forward? And what are the reasons
for the earnings
decline so far? And do we think it's going
to continue?
So are we in phase one, phase two, phase
three, phase four or phase five?
So for long ideas, the earnings growth
turnaround stories for potential longs
that we've looked at here are best
considered if we are in a phase four or
phase five situation of an X growth story.
We need to be very careful that we're not
getting into a long position
of an X growth stock where the earnings
growth profiles like cases eight and nine
are in phase one,
phase two or phase three, as these could
just be very bad long positions.
What we want to see is cases like case
eight and nine in phase four or five.
So the stock is down a lot.
It's been going down for a while, could be
one year, two years, three years.
It's been in phase four or phase five in
those scenarios for quite a long time.
We have the case eight or case nine
exhibited earnings growth profile.
And we're having an aggressive turnaround
in earnings growth.
So in the situation of case number eight,
we have a positive EPS situation with
negative earnings
growth in period one.
We have a positive EPS situation in period
two, but the earnings growth goes from
negative
to positive, at least at the sector level.
And in case number nine, we have a wild
turnaround in EPS where we go from
negative position,
loss making to profit making, and we go
from negative earnings growth to very
positive earnings growth.
And we're capturing this in phase four or
phase five, not in phase one, two or
three.
So we have potentially very big upside for
a turnaround story as a long position.
Now for shorts, it's a different
situation.
The earnings growth turnaround stories.
So the profiles that we've looked at for
potential short ideas are best considered
if we are in phase
two or phase three of an X growth
situation.
If we see earnings growth profiles like
the short cases five, eight and nine,
they could be in phase four or phase five,
and they could actually be genuine
turnarounds.
Or indeed, they could end up being value
traps.
So whoever ends up buying those stocks and
getting sucked in to the turnaround story,
they could end up having a bad position
and lose money because they may never
deliver
on the forecasted EPS and EPS growth
turnaround.
So they could be value traps and longs
could lose money.
But we don't care.
We are looking to optimize not just on
long positions, but also on short
positions.
We don't care because it's a phase four or
phase five scenario.
We just choose not to play.
So we look elsewhere, maybe in the same
sector or maybe in other sectors.
We look elsewhere for phase two and phase
three situations.
And we choose not to play.
We are going to optimize better somewhere
else with a short position.
So to put this in the most simple terms
possible.
For long ideas, we like our cases, case
eight and case nine, but we want them in
phase four or phase five.
For short ideas, we like our cases, case
five, eight and nine, but we want them in
phase two or phase three.
But we should always understand that these
are not ideal situations for both longs
and shorts.
For example, for a long idea, that's a
turnaround.
Of course, we can be wrong and it can be a
value trap and we can lose money.
The turnaround may not materialize and
things can get worse.
We have a 20 to 60 day time horizon and
our timing is very, very crucial.
Okay, especially for turnarounds.
So think about a situation where a stock
has been in phase four, then phase five
for a number of years.
If we're going to go long a turnaround
story in that situation, we need to
actually pick the financial quarter
So think about a stock for a moment that
goes from say $100 down to $20.
So we're down 80% over a three year
period.
And it's been trading between say $15 and
$25 for the last 18 months.
Okay, in that situation, if there is
genuinely a fundamental turnaround
happening, the stock may go from 20 to 30.
So it's up 50% in one quarter and we can
miss that 50%.
That's fine.
But we now have fundamental evidence that
the turnaround is happening.
It may be in most situations better
instead of trying to pick the quarter that
it's actually going to make that move
to let the move happen first, and then we
jump in in the next quarter and we can
ride that stock price up.
Because if there is a genuine turnaround,
fundamentally, the stock is so beaten up,
the stock is coming from such a low base,
that even catching it in the second
quarter, we're still going to have a lot
of upside.
For short ideas, we stay away from
shorting what we think are not
turnarounds.
So value traps that are in phase four and
phase five.
What we want from X growth names when we
are shorting,
we want these X growth names in phase two
and phase three.
There is absolutely no requirement to be a
hero when we're trading,
especially from the short side.
So returning to our earnings growth
profiles.
So our earnings growth profiles that are
non-ideal,
that exhibit characteristics of a
potential turnaround story or value trap.
So late stage X growth or earnings growth
profiles that exhibit
characteristics of potentially an early X
growth stock.
When we look at these profiles, so when we
refer to our profiles,
seven, eight, nine, 10 in the long
earnings growth profile download,
and we refer to five, eight, nine in the
download for earnings growth profiles for
shorts,
you will have realized by now or should
have realized that all of these profiles
are essentially similar or the same.
So the profiles overlap.
But what we're doing here is simply
looking at them through the lens of either
profit or loss making operations and as
potential longs or shorts.
So looking at them through a long lens or
a short lens.
And when we do this relative to other more
preferable earnings growth profiles for
long and short setups,
this is why they are not ideal and don't
fit the classic long and classic short
fundamental setups.
However, this doesn't mean that they're
not useful to us as traders.
These types of ideas have their place and
time in any long short equity portfolio.
So, for example, in a 10 stock portfolio
that's equally weighted with, say, six
longs and four shorts,
we may, as traders, portfolio managers at
any one time have a couple or two or three
of these positions
in the portfolio for diversification of
ideas purposes.
We can have these positions as long as
they are sized appropriately.
So if we are going to have long or short
positions in stocks that exhibit these
types of earnings growth profiles,
the key to success is going to be in our
ability to determine whether these stocks
are actually genuine
turnaround stories. So on the long side,
or X growth names, early stage X growth
names on the short side,
and with our timing. So whether we are in
phase one, two, three, four or five.
At this stage of our quantitative process,
we will have got to this stage by already
filtering
the forward looking estimates and
realizing that earnings growth profiles of
certain stocks within
a sector are not ideal. And the price
earnings ratios and pegs of those stocks
are telling us that
there's something potentially wrong with
the companies. We will have gone through
the sector and we will have
identified both positive and negative
outliers and identified the types of
profiles and types of trades
available within that sector. So that
being classic longs and shorts and
everything else in between.
Now we're hunting for X growth and
potential turnaround names. So when we've
gone through our sector
quant and our identification process, it's
now our job to go and find out what's
wrong with the companies
that exhibit these X growth and turnaround
profiles. Why they have poor valuation and
what is driving the bad earnings growth.
What is going on behind the curtain? And
the way we do this is through further
quantitative and qualitative work.
So first we do further quantitative work.
But we do a backwards looking quantitative
assessment of the company's balance sheet.
And then we do a forward looking
qualitative assessment of the management
operating plan.
So here and for the rest of this video,
we're going to be looking at a backwards
looking quantitative assessment and the
metrics that we use.
And remember at this stage, we have
already done a forward looking quant
process and identified a potential X
growth name or turnaround.
So we now go to the backwards looking
financial statements data of the balance
sheet and combinations of the balance
sheet and profit and loss account of the
company.
So we look at the last annual report and
or quarterlies if necessary to get a
snapshot of the financial health of the
company.
So with reference to our quantitative and
qualitative dashboard, we're going to be
looking at balance sheet metrics, debt to
equity ratio, interest coverage ratio,
current ratio, quick ratio, working
capital over total assets ratio and book
value per share.
We're also going to be looking at metrics
that combine data from the company's
balance sheet and the profit and loss
account.
So these are sales to assets ratio, return
on assets ratio, return on assets ratio,
return on equity, ROE.
We're also going to be looking at a metric
from the cash flow statement, free cash
flow yield, and inferring a metric called
price over free cash flow per share.
So now we are assuming that we've done our
work on the left hand side of the
dashboard.
So we've been through the identification
process of the quant phase where we've
used the filtering metrics of market cap,
earnings growth, revenue growth, PE ratio,
and PEG ratio.
We've checked our backwards looking
metrics like enterprise value, EBIT and
EBITDA, EV over EBIT and EV over EBITDA.
We've checked those metrics to learn more
about the stock and where stocks fit in
relative to the overall sector.
So we have a better understanding and good
understanding at this stage of how the
landscape of the sector is set out.
But we are also assuming here that we've
now identified what could potentially be
late stage X growth names.
So turnaround or value traps and also
potentially early stage X growth names.
So we've identified our cases of earnings
growth profiles that we've looked at
through a long lens and a short lens.
So our cases 8 and 9 looking through a
long lens and our cases 5, 8, 9 looking
through a short lens.
And we are now going to do a backwards
looking quantitative assessment looking at
static metrics from the past.
So from past annual accounts and also
potentially quarterly accounts.
And we're doing that to help us get a
better understanding of where we could be
in the X growth phase.
So we're looking to these metrics to give
us a litmus test of the overall financial
health of the company.
And in terms of financial health, where
we've come from, where we are at the last
set of accounts and where we could be
going.
But where we could be going ultimately
will come down to the quality of the
forward looking operation.
And that is going to be a forward looking
qualitative assessment.
And that is still to come and will come a
little bit further in the PTM video
series.
So first, let's have a look at our first
metric debt to equity ratio.
So debt to equity ratio, it's data taken
from the balance sheet.
We're looking at total debt over
shareholders equity or it can be
calculated as short term debt plus long
term debt plus other fixed payments over
shareholders equity.
So the debt to equity ratio measures how a
company is actually financing its
operations.
So in the case of an X growth stock or
potential turnaround stock, these would
constitute bad operations.
So a debt to equity ratio of one means
that the company is financing its
operations with an equal amount of debt
and equity.
A debt to equity ratio of two means that
the company is financing its operations
with twice the amount of debt versus
equity.
And a debt to equity ratio of 0.5 means
the company is financing its operations
with twice the amount of equity versus
debt.
Now, a debt to equity ratio of around two
or above in most industries is considered
dangerous, especially if the debt is
financing a contracting business.
So contracting operations.
So when we're doing further work and
looking at metrics like debt to equity
ratio in the context of a turnaround story
or perhaps something turning out to be a
value trap.
The debt to equity ratio provides a litmus
test on how difficult a turnaround will
likely be.
All things being equal, a turnaround will
be easier for a company that finances its
operations mostly with equity.
So it has a debt to equity ratio that's
one or below versus a company that
finances its operations with mostly debt.
So a debt to equity ratio that is above
one or way above one.
Now, a debt to equity ratio can't be used
in isolation to determine whether a
company is actually a turnaround or we're
getting sucked in to a value trap.
It must be used in conjunction with other
metrics to get an overall picture.
Most obviously, what we want to understand
is the debt distribution.
So the size of the corporate bonds, the
size of loans, the maturity of the debt,
the coupon and the interest payments.
And it's important to remember the context
here.
So the context that we're in.
We've arrived at this situation because we
are analyzing bad operations.
So operations that have already
contracted.
So it's important to remember that a
company's current operations is actually
financing the debt.
And we've arrived here because they've
already contracted.
Next up in our backwards looking quant, we
would look at interest coverage ratio,
which is EBIT over interest expense.
So the interest coverage ratio, it
measures how many times a company can
cover its current interest payments with
its available earnings.
So is the operation in a comfortable
position servicing their debt or not?
So for example, if a company made say $900
million of EBIT last year and had last
year in the last set of accounts,
$3 billion of debt at the end of the
financial year with a total interest
expense of $270 million,
then the interest coverage ratio is going
to be $900 million over the $270 million
of interest expense,
which is a 3.33 times multiplier.
This is a comfortable situation.
If a company, say, had an interest
coverage ratio of 0.9,
then this would probably be very bad,
especially when we're in the context of
contracting operations.
So in the context of assessing turnaround
stories or whether these turnaround
stories actually end up being value traps,
or even when we're analyzing X growth
names that are either early stage or some
way down the line,
the interest coverage ratio is important,
but it's necessary to understand that we
are looking at static numbers and
backwards looking data.
What you have to do as an exercise with
debt to equity ratio and interest coverage
ratio is calculate them
for each financial year and quarter over
time to see if the position has been
strengthening or worsening,
and also look to the reasons why it has
been strengthening or worsening.
Now, an interest coverage ratio of 2 is
generally considered the minimum
acceptable ratio across differing
industries,
but what is considered acceptable to the
market or not across different industries
differs.
Also, it's important to remember that
companies like governments also have
credit ratings,
and creditors will assess a company's
operations versus its ability to service
its debt
in order to issue new debt or not. The
credit ratings of the company's debt will
also depend on this.
Now, just as a side note, if you pull up
companies that are in trouble,
or on paper they look like they're in
trouble when we're looking at their past
backwards looking financial accounts.
So, for example, if a stock that has a
very high debt to equity ratio of 3.2 with
an interest coverage ratio of 1.3,
and they have operations that have already
cratered, the stock itself is probably
going to reflect this already.
It's probably already traveled.
So, it's important to remember this stuff
because we never want to be in a situation
where we're looking at past financial
statements,
looking at bad numbers, and then taking
positions like a short position in a
stock,
just because on paper, in the last set of
financial accounts, in a backwards looking
context, the numbers looked bad.
We need to always be thinking of looking
forwards,
because it's likely in this situation that
the stock has already traveled down.
Now, in terms of interest coverage ratio
in corporate credit markets,
we do have our credit ratings for
companies, and credit quality is evaluated
by credit agencies,
and it really matters.
It really matters because of the price of
or the interest of the debt,
and the risk and the spread of that debt
over the benchmark rate.
So, the 10-year treasury rate.
So, we have our various ratings for
corporate debt in the same way that we
have ratings for sovereign debt,
for government debt.
So, we have our investment grade, our A's,
and we have our high yield, and we have
our junk.
So, the company's ability to be able to
finance its debt via interest payments
from its current operations,
is assessed by the credit agencies, and it
will determine their future ability via
the credit rating.
It will determine the company's future
ability to finance its debt payments, but
also the company's ability
to issue more debt and the price or spread
or risk over the benchmark rate that this
debt is priced at.
So, credit ratings agencies will look to
the interest coverage ratio and use that
as an input into
determining the quality of the company's
credit and the credit rating.
So, for example, if you think back to our
previous example where we had an interest
coverage ratio of 3.33,
if we look at our credit ratings table,
this would constitute a credit rating of
investment grade.
So, above an interest coverage ratio of
3.33, if a company's earnings are falling,
so our EBIT is falling,
so the operations are contracting, and we
are, for example, in early stage X growth
and coming from an
investment grade rating where the interest
coverage ratio is above 3, if we can catch
that as a short
in phase 2 or phase 3, if the earnings of
the company, the operations, continue
cratering, then it could mean
that the credit of the company is going to
get downgraded by the ratings agencies.
And the interest on that debt will be
priced higher. Therefore, the spread
versus the benchmark,
the 10-year will blow out, making it even
more difficult for the company to use the
debt to
finance its operations that are cratering.
So, it is a continuous negative spiral.
They both affect each other.
On the flip side, let's say we identify
what could be a late-stage X growth
situation,
where we are in a potential phase 4 or
phase 5 scenario, and we have a very low
credit rating
via a low interest coverage ratio. So,
let's say we had an interest coverage
ratio of 0.8.
So, the company has a very high spread
over the benchmark over the 10-year, and
the company is
barely able to cover those interest
payments from their earnings. But looking
forward, we have a
management operating plan in place and
analysts are forecasting a turnaround in
earnings in the company.
So, what this could do if the forecast is
hit and it looks like earnings growth is
going to actually go
positive and accelerate. So, we're coming
from a cratering scenario in operations
and we are late-stage
with a low interest coverage ratio moving
into a situation where earnings are going
to go up by quite
a lot. This is going to improve the
interest coverage ratio and the company's
ability to service its debt.
The ratings agencies would put the rating
under review and we might see the debt of
the company
get upgraded in their rating. And
therefore, in the future when the company
issues new debt,
they would be issuing at a lower spread.
So, at a lower level of interest and this
debt would be used to
finance ever-growing operations. So,
again, we have both sides affecting each
other. The debt financing
operations and the operations determining
credit rating and the price or interest of
debt.
So, we have, in this instance, a positive
spiral.
But what if the company's earnings don't
actually turn around? So, earnings don't
go up as the market expects.
So, the operations just stay the same.
Well, in that situation, we've entered a
scenario of a value trap.
What's going to determine whether the
company turns its earnings around or not
and the fortunes of the
operations going forward is the quality of
the operation improving. So, that would be
our qualitative
assessment which we're going to look at
later. Now, next up, in our
backwards-looking financial
statements, quant metrics that we look at,
we're looking at now the current ratio,
which is current
assets over current liabilities. Current
assets is made up of cash and cash
equivalents that can be
accessed or liquidated within 90 days,
plus marketable securities that can be
liquidated within one year,
plus inventory, plus accounts receivable,
and other receivables. Current liabilities
is made up of
short-term debt, so notes that are payable
within one year, plus accounts and trade
payable, plus accrued
expenses, so taxes and interest invoice
that's not been received, and deferred
revenue.
Now, the current ratio is sometimes called
the working capital ratio, and it's a
liquidity ratio that measures
the company's ability to meet its
short-term obligations that are falling
due within one year.
So, a company, for example, that has a
current ratio of less than one, does not,
in many cases, have the
capital on hand to meet its short-term
obligations. So, for example, its
short-term debt obligations,
and perhaps accounts payable. So, if these
liabilities all came due at once, then the
company would be
technically insolvent. Now, a company with
a current ratio that's greater than one
indicates that the
company has the financial resources to
remain solvent in the short term. So, in
the context of a turnaround or
value trap situation, the current ratio
needs to be used in a similar way to the
debt-to-equity ratio and the
interest coverage ratio. It's best to look
at how the current ratio has changed over
time due to the cratering operations.
So, remember, in this context, we have
arrived at turnarounds because we have
already had cratering operations.
So, imagine the following scenario of a
company's current ratio where revenue and
EPS has already been
falling, so contracting for four years in
a row. So, in 2019, we have a current
ratio of 2.1.
In 2020, we have a current ratio of 1.6.
In 2021, current ratio is 1.1. And in
2022, current ratio is 0.87.
So, we can see that the company's position
in terms of its current ratio has been
deteriorating over the
four years. And if operations are still
cratering and there's an absence of a
strong management operating
plan, then this is likely to be a value
trap. Now, there is also another liquidity
ratio that we can add to
our armory when we're looking at
backwards-looking financial statements.
And that's the quick ratio.
So, the quick ratio is calculated as cash
and cash equivalents plus marketable
securities plus
accounts receivable over current
liabilities. Or, as an alternative
calculation, we have our cash and cash
cash equivalents plus marketable
securities and accounts receivable over
accounts payable.
So, the quick ratio is an even more liquid
focused version of the current ratio. And
it's sometimes
referred to in the market as the acid test
ratio. What it does is it measures a
company's ability
to pay its short-term liabilities by
having assets that are readily convertible
into cash.
So, you'll notice that the current assets
that is used in the numerator for the
quick ratio,
they don't include inventory or other
receivables. That's because it might take
too long to convert
inventory and other receivables into cash
to cover immediate liabilities if the
company is required to do so.
So, cash and cash equivalents plus
marketable securities and accounts
receivable are known as quick assets.
So, in the context of when we're analyzing
whether something could be a turnaround
story
or a value trap where we have a backdrop
of operations that have been sliding or
cratering in the past,
we can again not look at the quick ratio
as a snapshot or in isolation. We have to
look at it and how it's evolved over time.
So, in the same way as when we looked at
the current ratio when we had sliding
operations in the past,
moving to a situation that we're in at the
present, we look at the quick ratio in the
same way.
We have sliding operations coming to the
present and we look at how the quick ratio
has evolved over that time period when
operations have been contracting.
So, we get a barometer of what the
financial health of the company looks like
in terms of liquidity, so the quick ratio
and the current ratio.
Now, if you look at both of these numbers,
the current ratio and the quick ratio,
and you find that a company has a low
quick ratio that's say 1.1, but a high
current ratio of say 2.1, what does this
mean?
Well, it's the difference in the way the
calculations are done.
So, we would zoom in at the differences
and we would look to see if the company is
carrying a large amount of inventory.
And what is the inventory and can the
inventory even be sold and converted into
cash?
So, we would ask these questions and
figure out which is a more accurate
picture of the liquidity
and the financial health of the company,
whether it's the current ratio or the
quick ratio.
So, if we have a low quick ratio, but a
high current ratio,
then the inventory that the company is
carrying on its balance sheet,
if it can't be sold and quickly converted
into cash,
then the high current ratio may be
flattering the position of the company on
paper
and the reality is, is that the company is
at or near insolvency.
Next up is our working capital to total
assets ratio.
Again, taking the data from the past
balance sheet.
It is calculated as working capital over
total assets,
where working capital is current assets
minus current liabilities.
So, we take current assets, we take away
current liabilities.
So, current assets minus current
liabilities, and then we divide by total
assets.
So, we have a useful guide here from an
accounting perspective that would
constitute a good,
satisfactory, unsatisfactory, or critical
working capital to total assets ratio.
So, for example, if we had a company that
had current assets of 2.345 billion and
current liabilities of 2.166 billion,
we would minus off the liabilities from
the assets, and then we would divide by
total assets.
So, in this example, 6.498 billion, we
would get to a figure of 0.0275, which is
2.75%.
From an accounting perspective, this would
be seen as a critical position for a
company.
So, according to the table, if you do the
calculation for a company for working
capital to total assets ratio,
and you get a number of 0.3 or 30% or
above, this would be considered, from an
accounting perspective,
a very good, very strong position for a
company between 0.15 and 0.3, so 15% and
30%, this would constitute a satisfactory
position.
Between 0 and 15, this would constitute,
from an accounting perspective, an
unsatisfactory position,
and a ratio that's negative, so below 0,
it would be critical.
But, if it's very, very low and close to
0, it is essentially critical.
It's hovering just above 0, and it's
essentially in a very bad position.
The company is in a bad position. It is
basically in a critical scenario.
So, in the context of when we're assessing
something, a company, whether it's going
to be a potential
turnaround or potential value trap
scenario, this is an important measure.
So, in this situation where we have a
critical condition, management need to
make long-term asset
disposals and perhaps even raise capital
via an equity or debt offering.
So, they have to restructure the business.
And on top of that, they will also have to
turn around the operation as well.
If they can make some asset disposals,
even if there are non-favorable prices,
then we could see a turnaround in the cash
position.
They can use that to pay down some debt.
And we can therefore improve the numerator
in the working capital to total assets
ratio and therefore
improve the working capital position and
the working capital asset ratio itself.
Now, what if the numerator of working
capital was actually negative?
So, our current assets minus current
liabilities comes out as negative.
Then, of course, we're going to be in a
very critical position.
The ratio would just be negative.
Next up on the balance sheet, we can look
at book value per share or BVPS.
So, book value per share is stockholders'
equity minus preferred stock divided by
average shares outstanding.
So, book value per share is basically the
ratio of equity that's available to common
stockholders
against the number of shares outstanding.
And when we compare this to the current
stock price in the market, the book value
per share can provide us with information
on how the company is valued.
So, as in a premium or discount to book
value per share and the size of that
difference.
Now, in the context of assessing whether a
stock is a potential turnaround or even a
potential value trap,
and in combination with other quantitative
and qualitative metrics,
it gives us a good idea on the opportunity
and the risk of a potential trade idea.
So, the upside and downside on a long or
short position.
As a side note, by the way, for our
calculation, we are using the average
number of shares outstanding
options, because the closing period amount
may be different if there was a stock
issuance or
a share buyback program in the market.
Now, we can run through an example here of
book value per share.
So, let's say we have a company, XYZ
Corporation, and they have $4 billion of
stockholders' equity,
of which $1 billion is preferred stock,
and they have 60 million shares
outstanding over the period.
So, our book value per share would be
calculated as $4 billion minus $1 billion,
so the $3 billion divided by 60 million
shares.
So, that would give us a book value per
share of $2 billion, so that would give us
a book value per share of $50.
Now, if the current stock price is trading
at $62, we can say that the stock is
trading on 1.24 times book value per
share.
Now, let's say after assessing all other
quantitative metrics and the management
operating plan,
it might not be sensible to short this
stock, even if you think it's a value
trap.
So, even if you've determined that you
think earnings are still going to go
lower.
So, if earnings and retained earnings
shallow out and management have stopped
the EPS bleed
before even a new management operating
plan is even fully working, the risk
reward may not even work.
So, the stock may have traveled
significantly lower and value buyers could
be circling around
at the level of the book value per share
price, so this would indicate that we're
probably in a phase 4 or phase 5 scenario.
And this is exactly why we avoid shorting
these situations.
Because a short position in this scenario
may only provide $12 of upside in terms of
P&L on the short.
So, $12 upside of profit, but have
infinite downside.
We want to be seeing much better ROI on
our trades than that for shorts.
So, this is why we need to be in phase 2
and phase 3.
We would much rather be short stocks that
are traveling into a situation like this
rather than shorting stocks that are
actually in this situation.
So, does this mean the stock is actually
along? Not necessarily.
If you don't believe in the turnaround
story, so the management operating plan,
and you believe that
it's a potential value trap, then if the
stock has already traveled,
non-participation is always an option.
Something else to consider is that a
company can also increase its book value
per share by just buying back stock.
So, reducing the share count, the amount
of shares outstanding.
If the company has a decent amount of
short-term assets like cash and marketable
securities,
they might actually go and surprise the
market with a share buyback program,
whilst deploying the new management
operating plan for the turnaround.
And this could cause a stock to really
rally significantly.
So again, book value per share from our
balance sheet is a metric
that can't be used simply in isolation.
We need to look at book value per share in
the context or next to all other balance
sheet ratios
and financial health metrics.
Now, we're going to move on from looking
at just a company balance sheet
to now looking at metrics that combine
data from both a company balance sheet
and a company's profit and loss statement.
And the first one we're going to look at
is the sales to assets ratio,
which is net sales over average total
assets,
where average total assets is equal to
assets at the start of the year,
plus assets at the end of the year,
divided by two.
Now, the sales to assets ratio is
sometimes called the asset turnover ratio.
And this metric measures the efficiency of
a company.
How well a company is using its assets to
generate sales.
And it's almost always calculated on an
annual basis.
And the higher the ratio, the better.
However, we do need to be careful when
we're thinking that a sales to assets
ratio
is useful when we're comparing that number
across industry sectors.
This is just folly.
It's foolish because they can differ
wildly.
So for example, analyzing the sales to
asset ratio of a tech stock versus a
utility that has massive
fixed asset investment and low sales in
comparison to the investments made is
meaningless.
You have to analyze sales to assets ratios
within the same sector and through time to
determine
if asset utilization is either
deteriorating or improving.
Now, in the context of figuring out if
something is actually a turnaround story
or not,
what the sales to assets ratio is going to
likely already be low versus the sector.
But it helps us fill in another gap in
understanding the overall story.
If a stock has fallen materially already
and we see that the sales to assets ratio
has deteriorated rapidly
and is now low but stable, then in
combination with other ratios that we've
looked at,
we may decide that this could be the signs
of the beginning of a turnaround.
So we are sitting potentially in a phase
four or phase five scenario.
Ideally, what we'd like to see when we're
sitting in that phase four or phase five
scenario,
as always, is a management operating plan
that gives some visibility to a turnaround
and maybe even some noises about
restructuring.
So there is a flip side to this if we
don't actually see that.
And we have a low sales to assets ratio
where we have no management operating plan
looking going forward
and no restructuring plan or activity.
This may cause us to decide that we should
avoid it as a turnaround long idea
because it could be potentially a value
trap.
Now, there is a drawback, a blind spot
that we need to take account of with the
sales to assets ratio calculation
because it doesn't take into account the
company making asset investments.
So if the company invests in a new asset
and it's a big investment, the ratio could
look low.
But future sales estimates could now be
going higher.
It has to be looked at in the context of a
management operating plan.
A restructuring plan can really change
everything very quickly.
Now, another balance sheet profit and loss
statement combo metric that we look at
is called the return on assets ratio or
the ROA ratio.
And it can be calculated in two ways.
There's two ways of doing this.
ROA can be net income over total assets
or it can be net income over average total
assets, where again, the average total
assets is assets
at the start of the year plus assets at
the end of the year divided by two.
Now, the ROA ratio is similar to the sales
to assets ratio, as in it's an efficiency
metric.
So it works out how efficient a company is
versus its sector peers.
However, instead of using the sales number
as the numerator, we use net income.
So it's a profitability measure.
Therefore, a return on investment measure.
So an ROI measure.
So it's measuring how many dollars of
profit
a company generates for every dollar that
is invested in assets.
So in the context of analyzing a potential
turnaround story, the ROA ratio is likely
to already be low versus the sector.
And if a stock has fallen materially
already, and we see that the ROA ratio has
already deteriorated
rapidly and is now low and stable, then in
combination with other ratios, we may
decide
that this could be the signs of the
beginning of a turnaround where we're in
phase four or phase five.
And yes, even better if we see a visible
management operating plan and some noises
about restructuring.
But like the sales to assets ratio on the
flip side, a low ROA with no restructuring
activity
and no visible management operating plan,
this may cause us to decide to avoid it as
a turnaround long idea.
In terms of drawbacks, we do have the same
issue with the ROA ratio as with the sales
to assets ratio.
That being it doesn't take into account
recent asset investments.
So if the company invests in a new asset,
makes a big investment in that asset,
the ratio could look low, but future
earnings estimates could now be going
higher.
It has to be looked at in the context of
the management operating plan.
And a restructuring plan can change
everything very quickly.
Our next balance sheet P&L combo is return
on equity, which can be calculated in two
ways.
Firstly, net income over shareholders
equity or net income over average
shareholders equity,
where the average shareholders equity is
calculated as shareholders equity at the
start of the year,
plus shareholders equity at the end of the
year, divided by two.
Now a return on equity percentage, it
measures a company's ability to turn
equity investments into a profit.
And this differs from the ROA, the return
on assets ratio percentage, because that
includes debt.
However, it is similar in that it's an ROI
measure of profitability and efficiency of
how
dollars are utilized by the company. Now,
in the context of a turnaround,
we know that earnings have already been
falling for a while.
And with some of our earnings growth
profiles, they are forecast to potentially
fall further
and that we could be in a value trap
scenario.
So again, to get better context, we have
to look at this metric through time
and compare it to sector peers to
determine if there's been deterioration or
any improvement.
And we need to figure out where we are in
the bigger picture by using other
financial statement, quantitative metrics.
And we need to be figuring out what likely
phase we are in when the company has gone
X growth.
So are we in phase one, two, three, four
or five?
So remember, for value traps, for
potential shorts, we don't like phase four
and phase five,
even if the management operating plan
looks suspect.
It can be low market cap and there may be
value buyers around and they're probably
not lurking too far away.
For turnarounds, for longs, we like phase
four and phase five, but we need to see a
convincing management operating plan.
And we need to time the trade very well
because we are operating in the 20 to 60
day time horizon.
Now, just as a side note, when we're
comparing ROE versus ROA,
if ROE is materially higher than ROA, it's
because the denominator in ROA compared to
ROE is much bigger.
And this will be because the company has a
lot of debt.
So it's actually a good step to compare
the ROA and the ROE versus each other
because they're both efficiency ratios for
net income, one over assets and one over
shareholders equity.
So how efficient the company is in turning
assets into profit and turning equity into
profit.
And looking at the difference between the
two to get a better understanding of the
stock.
And in the context of a turnaround story
or even identifying something that's early
stage X growth,
looking at how efficient a company is and
how efficient it's being run helps us in
assessing
the possibility of whether a company will
continue its X growth slide
or the probability that the company can
turn around the fortunes of earnings.
Now, the last metric that we're going to
look at is a cash flow metric.
And we're going to look briefly at free
cash flow yield.
But a derivative of this that we've worked
out is actually more important, which is
the price over free cash flow per share
metric.
So firstly, if we look at free cash flow
yield and look at the calculation of that,
it is the last annual free cash flow per
share over the current market stock price.
So this is the backwards looking metric
for free cash flow yield.
There is also another calculation, which
is a forward looking metric,
which is the annualized free cash flow per
share over the current market stock price.
But we can work this out the other way
around and we can get the multiple that
the market is willing to pay
for the free cash flows of the company on
a per share basis.
And we can get this as a forward looking
measure.
So instead of doing annualized free cash
flow per share over current market stock
price,
we flip this around.
So we do current market stock price
divided by annualized free cash flow per
share.
And what that gives us is the price over
free cash flow per share metric,
which as traders and investors, we treat
in a similar way to price earnings ratio,
where we have the stock price over EPS.
In this instance, we have the stock price
over free cash flow per share.
And similar to price earnings ratio,
academia in finance will teach you that
low price over free cash flow per share is
a good thing,
that it's cheap and a high price over free
cash flow per share is bad.
It's expensive.
Fortunately, we are not finance professors
teaching at a university.
We are traders and traders know better.
However, a stock can be on the same price
to free cash flow per share and keep going
lower and it can keep going higher.
Now, this is a dangerous situation for us
in the context of turnarounds,
because we are already at the point where
negative earnings growth is forecast to
occur and or losses.
So the operation is cratering and probably
cash flow with it.
So it's likely that the stock price itself
has already traveled lower or is already
traveling much lower.
And we are looking at a backwards number.
So PE and price over free cash flow per
share are likely to already be low versus
the sector.
And the market is telling us that they are
willing to sell the earnings
and the cash flow of the company at a
discount to the sector.
And based on expectations going forward,
there may be a hope number from analysts
for a turnaround in EPS and cash flow.
And what are we doing?
We are sitting here saying we think that
there could be a turnaround that's going
to happen in the stock.
Meanwhile, we have low PE relative to the
sector and we have low price over free
cash flow per share.
Again, relative to the sector.
So essentially, we are arguing with the
valuation of the market.
We are arguing with the market.
So we need to take note of this.
We need to understand our risk and we need
to acknowledge this.
We need to acknowledge that if we are in a
turnaround situation or calling a
turnaround situation,
we are arguing with low PE and low price
over free cash flow per share.
Where our edge comes in is fully
understanding the quality of the operation
and the quality of the earnings moving
forward.
And this comes from our qualitative
analysis.
So if we can do a solid qualitative
analysis and we realize that earnings and
free cash flow
position at the company is going to
improve in the future to an extent that is
better than the current market consensus,
then, of course, there is an opportunity
here to take advantage of a potential big
turnaround.
Additionally, we simply don't have to
participate if we don't want to in calling
the quarter the
financial quarter of the turnaround.
We can do our work.
We can understand everything that's
driving the potential turnaround and we
can miss the first quarter
and catch the next quarter.
What the price over free cash flow per
share metric does is it gives us a
comparison and potential
confirmation on valuation when we compare
it to price earnings ratio.
Therefore, we can understand our overall
risk of calling a turnaround or even the
stage of an X growth scenario.
We can call it and understand it better.
Now, in summary, when we are analyzing
whether a stock in this position is a
genuine turnaround story or not.
So it may materialize, but it becomes a
value trap.
There is no right or wrong answer at this
stage of the process.
What we have done is we have identified
these cases by doing our forward looking
quantitative analysis.
So identifying positive and negative
outliers in a sector and everything else
in between.
Once we have identified potential
turnarounds, we then go through the
checklist of the backwards looking
financial metrics that we've just looked
at to get a snapshot of the company versus
its sector peers.
So we get a context and an interpretation
of the company numbers and the sector
numbers overall.
So where does the company fit in overall
compared to the sector?
Now, on top of that, we have to look at
the company's plans to turn things around.
So the management operating plan, that is
a qualitative assessment.
So we will be going through an entire
section on qualitative assessment, but we
won't be looking at turnarounds or value
traps in isolation.
What we will be doing is teaching you the
qualitative process for all classic longs
and shorts and turnarounds and value
traps.
So you can generate trade ideas yourself.
So the process will apply to all profiles.
For a turnaround to be genuinely on the
cards, there must be a viable, aggressive
and believable new management operating
plan in place.
What are we going to typically see?
We're going to typically see capital
restructurings, divestment of
underperforming assets at sometimes very
unattractive prices.
We're going to see investment in new
assets, new businesses, new products and
services that are performing.
We're going to see things like headcount
reduction, so layoffs.
We're going to see a reorganization of
operations and we're going to see new
products and services get launched.
Additionally, with potential turnarounds
or X growth scenarios, we always have to
remember our time horizon as traders.
We are not investors, so we need to do our
quantitative process.
We need to do our qualitative process.
We have to have a very good timing
assessment and also solid trade
structuring, which is part of the POTM,
the options trading masterclass, which we
won't be covering in this video series.
So we have to do our quant, our
qualitative, our timing and our trade
structuring very well.
Now we've come to a stage in the video
series where it might be worth thinking
about what
a long short portfolio is going to look
like or potentially look like when we
consider the different profiles that we've
looked at for earnings growth.
And the different characteristics of
different types of longs and different
types of short ideas that make up a long
short portfolio.
So, for example, let's have a look at the
earnings growth profiles and stock
characteristics of a theoretical
10 stock portfolio that has a $100,000
notional risk with a net long bias that is
non beta adjusted.
So starting with the longs, we have six
longs in this portfolio.
That's giving us our net long bias because
for our shorts, we only have four shorts.
So starting with our longs, trade idea
number one.
This could be a situation where we have a
classic long sequentially positive
earnings growth profile
that is characterized as cyclical. So we
have our long case one.
Trade idea two can also be a classic long
sequentially positive earnings growth
profile
that is characterized as cyclical. Again,
a long case one.
Trade idea three. We could also have
another growth stock in the portfolio,
but this time it's not earnings growth.
It's revenue growth. So we could have
sequentially positive
revenue growth with no earnings. And the
company has a high R&D component
as part of its overall operation. And this
is also characterized as cyclical.
And this doesn't fit into our any earnings
growth profiles as cases because it's a
revenue growth
story. Moving on to trade number four.
Trade idea number four. We could have
positive earnings
growth in period one that's above sector
average and less positive, but still above
sector average
in period two. And this stock could be
characterized as a defensive from a
defensive sector. And this
would be our long case number three. Trade
number five. This could be again a classic
long sequentially
positive earnings growth profile, but not
in a cyclical sector in this case, in a
defensive sector. So
characterized as a defensive stock. This
is again our long case number one, but we
are in now a defensive
sector. Trade number six. We could have a
completely different type of position in
the portfolio as a
long. We could have a believable
turnaround story with an aggressive
management operating plan and catalysts.
And this can be characterized as cyclical
as well. This is our long case number
nine. But there's a
caveat. We want this to be characterized
as having either phase four or phase five
characteristics. We
want to be in that scenario. So here we're
assuming that it's in a phase five
scenario.
Moving on to the shorts. We have four
shorts in this theoretical portfolio.
Trade idea number seven.
We could have a classic short sequentially
negative earnings growth that is cyclical.
And this is our
short case number one. But we have what is
crucial to our shorts. We have phase two
characteristics.
Moving on to trade idea number six. Moving
on to trade idea number eight. We have an
earnings growth profile
in period one that is flat. Then going to
negative earnings growth that's below
sector average in
period two. And this would be our short
case number three. And we have phase three
characteristics.
Moving on to our trade idea number nine.
We have an earnings
growth profile where we have negative
earnings growth in period one. But then in
period two,
less negative earnings growth, but it's
still negative. And in both periods, I'm
not performing the sector.
And our characteristic of this stock is
that it's a defensive stock. This is our
case. Short case
number two. And we have phase two
characteristics. Our next short trade idea
on our last number 10.
We can have an early X growth cyclical
with a bad management operating plan that
has a high market cap.
So over 20 billion market cap with an
earnings growth profile that matches our
case number eight,
our short case number eight. And this can
have phase three characteristics.
So at this stage, guys, it's good to
understand how all of this is fitting
together.
We're not going to have a situation when
we build long short portfolios,
where we are simply just long growth names
all the time. We're going to have
different types of longs
across the book, characterized as
different types of longs. And we're going
to have shorts in our
portfolio because we are long short
managers. And we're going to be short X
growth names at the right
phases of them going X growth. And our
shorts can also be a good mixture of
different types of shorts,
different types of characteristics. So you
can see here now, the types of portfolios
that we're working
towards. Now in this video, we've
obviously covered a lot of ground when it
comes to turnaround stories,
the different earnings growth profiles and
how we characterize them and how we look
at them through
a long and short lens. We've also looked
at our balance sheet and our combo metrics
that are
backwards looking financial statements.
We've done analysis on that. We've done
process on that.
And we've done some interpretation in the
context of turnarounds. However, all of
these backwards looking
financial metrics that we looked at, they
can all be used in your regular analysis
when you're doing a
deeper dive on even classic long and short
setups. So please use them in all of your
analysis,
even when you're looking at classic longs
and shorts. Always, always follow the
process.
Forward looking quantitative discovery,
which is the identification phase. We do
that first.
Then we have our backwards looking quant
phase, which is the evidence phase. That
comes second. And then
we have third, our forward looking
qualitative phase. It's important that you
follow the process and not
try to skip steps and jump steps in order
to try and take shortcuts. You need to
follow the process.
The better you get at it, the quicker
you're going to get at it.
Now we've come to the end of turnaround
stories and value traps as a video.
We're now going to move straight in to the
next video where we're going to be having
a look at
data processing and mining mistakes and
solutions. So I'll see you in the next
video.